dumplings are a popular cuisine made by
a variety of flavors from around the
world they can be sweet or savory
steamed boiled baked or fried in Chinese
cuisine dumplings have been refined to
an art form and are often eaten on
special occasions like Chinese New Year
to make a dumpling
you first wrap a thin layer of dough
around a filling dumplings can come in
many different shapes these are filled
with shrimp and pork
food prep technicians at this facility
peel devein and sort shrimp for
different kinds of dumplings as they
work they double check each shrimp for
freshness and quality the 30 people
working at this station and peeled
10,000 shrimp per hour to make the
dumpling dough technicians begin the
process by pouring all-purpose flour
into this large mixing bowl they add
water at a ratio of two parts flour to
one part water a large dough hook mixes
the two ingredients together
[Music]
periodically the technicians stop the
machine to manually test the dough for
consistency it's not ready yet
after more mixing they test it again
this time is just right soft and still
elastic
[Music]
to strengthen the dose structure a
worker begins folding and rolling it
into lengths
[Music]
at the next station food prep
technicians rip small chunks off the
rolls
[Music]
then they weigh the chunks to ensure
they meet the parameter of just point
two eight ounces apiece
two additional technicians collect the
chunks and follow a two-step process in
which they stand each piece on its round
end before flattening it they sprinkle
the round disks with flour to keep them
from sticking to each other when moved
to the next station
[Music]
the next step uses traditional cooking
tools to transform each disk into a
wrapper for a dumpling known as Xiao Mai
the food prep technicians wear
protective clothing to prevent
contamination in house quality control
inspectors test the airborne bacteria
levels in the facility every month to
ensure that it meets the necessary
standards creating the Xiao Mai wrapper
requires high levels of skill this
workers right hand rolls the dough while
his left hand rotates the wrapper in
perfectly coordinated movements turning
out wafer thin rounds at high speed a
second worker uses a different style of
rolling pin to crimp the edges of the
wrapping
the technicians on the Left use a wooden
spatula to scoop a portion of filling
and to each wrapper before placing them
on a scale to ensure the weight is
correct technicians on the right top off
each dumpling with a shrimp
[Music]
inserting the shrimp is another step
that requires carefully orchestrated
hand movements to accomplish the task
with speed and elegance the worker is
able to carefully tuck the shrimp into
place with effortless movements of one
hand dumplings come in all shapes and
sizes at another table workers assemble
a delicacy in the shape of a Halfmoon
these dumplings start out with the same
disc shaped wrapper and the same shall
my filling next a worker uses a special
crimping technique pinching a series of
small creases in the dough to seal them
in a completely different way by
carefully arranging each dumpling
technicians can fit nearly eighty eight
of them in one pan thanks to an amazing
artisanal assembly line of skilled
workers the final product is almost too
beautiful to eat